well let's find out what labor I have to
say about that and many other things
this morning in the form of Jim McMahon
uh with us now Hi how are you good okay
how are you uh nurses might be
struggling but they're not having any
more money well I just think this shows
the government is out of touch with
public opinion uh and the government
haven't delivered on their promise to
respect those Frontline workers who kept
the nation going during covert you know
working very long ago I was working in
very difficult circumstances and all
they're asking for now a point to which
they're struggling to make ends to me
and we've all seen the price of food go
up the energy bills have gone up
mortgage payments are going up uh nearly
every month at the moment and you know
people genuinely are struggling and for
the government not to hear that just
from a human point of view I think this
shows that they're told deaf to public
opinion you're here to talk about the
national Farmers
um Union they're holding um a conference
today aren't they and so Care staff is
going to tell them why labor is the
party of farmers I always thought it was
the tourist well I think for a long time
they were considered to be the uh the
party of uh of our counters and our
shires and of the farm and community and
I've got to tell you over the last 13
years they have completely demolished
that reputation with the the way that
they treated farmers the way that
they've dealt with our food security
where in on one hand you've got farmers
who feel so frustrated that they haven't
got government support and if you're a
consumer you're going into the
supermarket and seeing the shelves are
empty why because the government are not
on the side of farmers they're not on
the side of food security and as a
result you know in the end consumers are
paying the price I thought the shells
were empty because of bad weather in
Morocco but we do grow produce here but
it's a matter of fact that we're not
growing tomatoes here for instance
because the cost of energy in the
greenhouses is so high that they've just
been turned off that is a contributing
factor to why there are gaps on the
supermarket shelves you know the reason
why you can't buy eggs on Pancake Day in
many supermarkets is because of avian
flu and the government could have
responded much quicker to that and
Farmers feel very frustrated in the way
that they've been treated but the reason
why Kia is going to Birmingham today and
I'll be going uh shortly of course is to
thank Farmers for keeping the nation fed
in very difficult circumstances and also
to say that they will get a government
on their side under a labor government
with a clear plan to make sure that we
back them up but also that we use a
public pound to buy more sell more
British produce and would you row back
on trade deals with countries like
Australia and New Zealand it's certainly
about making sure that British interests
are protected in those deals and all the
visits I do around the country uh to
Farmers say that people feel really
frustrated you know of course we want to
maintain really high levels of Animal
Welfare standards of environmental
standards we want to be good custodians
of the natural environment and Wildlife
but on the other hand the government are
striking deals to lesser standards to
other countries they'll allow food to be
brought in at a lower cost undercutting
farmers and producers here we don't
think that's fair we think there should
be a Level Playing Field and that's what
farmers are asking for and I think the
government will hear that in Birmingham
this week so are you going to rip up the
deals with the Aussies and the kiwis
it's not about ripping up trade deals
it's about saying there certainly needs
to be Revisited to make sure that they
act in our national interest and they
act in our food security interest it's
no good saying that you you are the
government on the side of food security
if we're not going to have a vibrant
farming and food sector if they feel
undercut if they can't make ends meet
that will of course have parts of our
food security so basically you're going
to look again at both of those deals
well we've been very critical of those
trade deals in particularly the the
Australian trade deal in the way that we
are allowing potentially the Imports of
food into the country that are produced
to lower animal welfare and nature
standards of course that's produced at a
lower cost it undercuts our own British
farmers and producers and that means in
practice that fans potentially being
pushed to the brinkie even more on top
of the labor crisis on top of the energy
crisis on top of the input costs on food
and fertilizer and we think that the
government needs to look again I was
chatting to Peter hay and I don't know
if you saw a previous Northern Ireland
Secretary of course as you know when
labor was in power and he was saying
it's an absolute mess what's going on
with the Northern Ireland protocol but
he is hopeful that a deal could be done
but there would have to be some sort of
Border basically down the RAC well
that's to be a border somewhere if
you're changing moving goods from one
Customs area to another that's just a
matter of fact now in reality that
Customs border could be in Manchester it
could be Birmingham it could be in
Canary Wharf it could be in this room
because their online declarations their
digital declarations that can be still
down the Irish sea to all defense
purposes that but visually you do need
to have a border in place for checks on
regulation to make sure that food is
being passed safely the goods that are
passing do meet the standards of the
Customs area they're passing into that
does have to happen somewhere so where
would I ever want it until the question
then comes or where do you put it you
put it on the island of Ireland yeah and
create a physical border with all the
symbolism that comes with that we don't
think that's the right approach or do
you do it in the ioc which is not as
Visual and actually can be managed with
technology in a fast move away in
reality there will have to be compromise
and the government are going to have to
negotiate to make sure that that
compromise is seen through and we said
to the government listen this is so
important that we get this right that if
they need labor support to get it
through Parliament then we'll do that
but Rishi sunak has got to address the
divisions in his own party that could be
the stumbling block to this because the
people of Northern Ireland deserve
better so it is a border in the Irish
years what labor would prefer well there
will be a border anyway in terms of
customers should it be on the island of
Ireland or should it be in the Irish sea
and from what you're saying it looks as
though labor would support one down the
Irish well let's see the full deal when
it comes
um at the moment that seems to be the
indication and we're saying if that
strikes the right balance if it has a
compromise that allows it to settle uh
the matter and to get Goods moving back
and forward in the way that they ought
to in the long term rather than this
stick in plaster politics that we see at
the moment then of course we will step
up in the National interest and support
that just to talk about Kate Forbes
Before I Let You Go She's emerging as
one of the Front Runners for the a job
as first Minister after Nicholas
sturgeon's stepped down she said that
she would have voted against gay
marriage as a matter of conscience what
do you think
uh we're certainly not my view uh I
believe uh Britain is a welcoming an
inclusive place and one that is very
open-minded for people to live a decent
fulfilled life in the way that they
choose to I don't think those views
reflect the country as a whole okay good
job team thanks for joining us